tous ces et merci d'avoir choisi france
cela fait donc un mois jour pour jour
que les russes ont lancé leur offensive
en ukraine 4 semaines que les ukrainiens
vivent au rythme des bombardements
russes marioupol kharkiv irp in odessa
micola il faut tant de villes dont les
noms nous sont maintenant tristement
familier un mois après le début de cette
guerre force est de constater que les
destructions sont immenses mais aussi
que l'armée russe patine alors jusqu'à
maintenant au dessin n'avait pas été
bombardés mais ça y est cette ville
stratégique aux bords de la mer noire a
été visé par des frappes russe ville
hautement stratégique car en la
contrôlant on contrôle la kz logistique
entre la mer noire et kiev on va
retrouver tout de suite entre envoyé
spécial sur trame sur place julie dongle
of bonjour pour l'instant les tirs de
missiles russes sont encore sporadiques
sur odessa
oui en tout à fait ce matin cinq tirs de
missiles russes ont été tirés depuis la
mer noire à 6h40 les alarmes ont donc
résonner les sirènes ont donc résonné
dans la ville d'odessa ainsi que les
cloches des églises 1 pour demander à la
population de se mettre à l'abri et cela
fait plusieurs jours maintenant que nous
entendons très régulièrement ses sirènes
qui a alerte de ces tiers russe en mer
noire dimanche et bien c'est des maisons
d'habitation qui avait été touché nous
avons été ce matin avec amaral à
mehdaoui à la rencontre du maire de
dessin pour lui poser la question sur
son sentiment quant au risque d'une
attaque imminente sur odessa je vous
propose de l'écouter
et le début de l'acte chômage continue
quand je donne une autre non nous ne
pensons pas à une attaque dans la
seconde où la minute mais cela pourrait
arriver dans les deux trois quatre
prochains jours
cela dépend des succès ou des échecs des
troupes russes
à vos semis et 5 et amicaux live
la municipalité se prépare à assurer la
sécurité des habitants en cas d'invasion
russe
on a préparé les abris fait des réserves
de médicaments de nourriture préparée
les hôpitaux
tout est prêt pour pouvoir fournir de
l'aide humanitaire quand il le faudra
julie comment vit la population
d'odessa sous cette menace d'une de
bombardements intenses de la russie
vient comme vient de le dire le maire
d'odessa la population se prépare c'est
ce que nous constatons maintenant depuis
plusieurs jours que nous sommes ici il
ya plus de deux cent mille personnes qui
ont quitté la ville mais ce et qui sont
restés bien participent à l'effort de
guerre on voit certains jeunes qui
apprennent à manier les armes on voit
également d'autres jeunes et bien qu'ils
tentent d'assurer la logistique qui est
notamment rassemble des vivres rassemble
des médicaments rassemble des pansements
pour être prêt au moment de l'offensive
on voit également des gens qui
remplissent inlassablement des sacs de
sable sur la plage de dessin pour
renforcer les défenses de la ville qui
installe également des obstacles anti
char pour bloquer l'accès à la ville ça
on peut le constater tous les jours ici
à odessa y est un fait un peu nouveau et
ce depuis notamment et bien que au
dessin a été touché des maisons
d'habitations ont été touchées dimanche
des gens commencent à organiser leur vie
souterraine c'est à dire que odessa
compte d'immenses catacombes 2500 km2
catacombes sous la ville à 20 mètres
sous terre hier nous avons tourné un
reportage dans ces cas dagon mais on a
pu observer et bien que la population
est en train d'emmener et délits
d'emmener de l'eau d'emmener des
médicaments d'emmener de quoi manger
d'emmener de quoi vivre plusieurs jours
là bas et puis il ya un sentiment très
étrange dans cette ville parce que par
ailleurs et bien ce que font les gens
c'est qu'ils observent énormément ce qui
se passe un peu plus loin à 130
kilomètres d'ici nicolas yves c'est la
mer la ville dont parlait le maire de
des salins ce temps là les combats sont
très importants nous avons eu l'occasion
de nous y rendre et bien ce qu'observent
les habitants d'odessa sait à quel point
nicolas yves point ce temps semble
résister et certains s'accrochent à cet
espoir pour se dire et bien que
l'offensive sur rodez ça ne sera pas
pour tout de suite
merci beaucoup je lui donne de l'ofs
envoyé spécial à odessa merci à vous